[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le magazine
est consacrée comme vous le savez à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire golf la
103e édition de l'open de france s'est
achevé ce dimanche 20 octobre sur les
greens de saint quentin en yvelines
le tournoi a été remporté par le belge
nicolas colsaerts les français terminent
dans le top 20 nous vous proposons de
revivre ces quatre jours de compétition
cyclisme la présentation du parcours
officiel du tour de france 2020 était
organisée ce mardi 15 octobre
le peloton s'élancera une nouvelle fois
depuis les yvelines pour rejoindre les
champs-elysées cette année à mantes la
jolie a été retenue comme ville départ
les détails dans quelques instants
handball coup de projecteur sur la
victoire de plaisir en nationale 3
contre boigny du tort qui permet à
l'équipe de remonter au classement le
résumé dans ce magazine l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
on part tout de suite du côté du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
103e édition de l'open de france s'est
achevé ce dimanche sur les greens de
l'albatros avec la victoire du belge
nicolas colsaerts les français terminent
eux dans le top-20 nous vous proposons
de revivre ces quatre jours de
compétition regard des remarques fini à
pour le montage
[Musique]
la 103e édition de l'open de france de
golf débute ce jeudi à 17 octobre au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
petite particularité cette année à les
français font partie à des favoris nous
les avons entendus en conférence de
presse mon objectif cette semaine
forcément de de performer au mieux
d'essayer de le prendre comme n'importe
quelle semaine même si forcément c'est
difficile d'être en france
et voilà après c'est de nous concentrer
sur le jeu je connais le parcours ce qui
est un avantage
déjà c'est de faire un bon open de
france en général le parcours est très
différent des autres années il va être
plus abordables les conditions est plus
compliqué donc ça va être un mix de
juristes s'étaient focalisés sur les
choses que je me que je contrôle que je
maîtrise
après voilà je suis dans une bonne
dynamique à mes côtés et thomas levet
qui a gagné le tournoi cet open de
france vous êtes le dernier français ce
qu'un français va vous succéder moi
c'est ce que j'espère c'est que j'ai mis
sur les réseaux sociaux j'espère que
cette année quelqu'un va te faire passer
ex anciens vainqueurs
dernier français de l'open de france je
vous ferais plaisir ah oui beaucoup de
plaisir et puis surtout il ya beaucoup
de jeunes qui se battent pour gagner des
tournois comme ça sur les tournois
internationaux il ya de très très jeune
même des amateurs qui joue le tournoi
cette semaine et pour eux c'est beaucoup
d'expérience de jouer de profiter de cet
open de france qui a un petit peu
descendu en classement dans l'ordre des
tournois du circuit européen mais mais
ça permet justement aux jeunes
générations de jouer le tournoi et c'est
vraiment le point positif de cet open
[Musique]
paul est un mythe edge le directeur du
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines et à mes côtés paul comment ça
se passe cette première journée de
compétition très très très bien en fait
on n'a pas eu une goutte de pluie ce qui
est ce qui est formidable
le parcours les joueurs en plébiscité
hier et avant-hier dans le lait les
interviews donc on est content ça c'est
notre objectif ça c'est notre rôle c'est
de produire un parcours la hauteur de
l'événement et puis là on est à mi
journée à peu près un petit peu plus de
la mi-journée puis les français jouent
bien au niveau les installations est ce
que vous êtes satisfait oui très parce
que les sponsors a changé je le rappelle
à chênée était le sponsor principal
l'année précédente cette année c'est
amundi qui a repris le relais est ce que
vous êtes satisfait oui oui oui c'est
différent parce que on n'est pas du tout
à notre date depuis 15 ans dans
l'habitude d'avoir le dernier week-end
de juin au premier week-end de juillet
et là on est mi octobre donc ça nous
change au niveau de la physionomie un
peu au niveau des vêtements par exemple
mais mais franchement il ya de quoi
amusé et occuper le public qui vient
vous attendez de combien de personnes
sur cet événement alors là là je peux
pas vraiment vous dire des chiffres
c'est vrai que ce matin
il y avait des gens devant la porte on
va dire à huit heures du matin on a des
indicateurs qui sont extrêmement bon
pour le week-end ce qu'il nous faut
vendredi soir c'est un français en tête
nous allons justement rencontrer les
spectateurs qui sont présents ici au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
on est venu supporter un peu les
français on aime bien venir au golf
national
j'ai rarement tous les ans on est venu
ici pendant la ryder cup
donc moi je suis golfeur depuis depuis
longtemps donc on aime bien venir
supporter les équipes et voleurs devant
le golf c'est toujours un plaisir
c'est l'occasion aussi de voir des
joueurs qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
au pouvoir approcher d'aussi près dans
d'aussi bonnes conditions notamment les
français notamment les français on
essaie de venir tous les ans parce que
c'est quand même l événement l'événement
golf en france de l'année donc
donc c'est sûr que c'est toujours
sympathique à voir à l'issue de cette
première journée de l'open de france le
sud-africain cozzi et le néo-zélandais
ryan fox sont premiers avec un coup
d'avancé
le premier français benjamin hebert est
dans le top 10 à un coup des leaders
je suis content je fais une bonne
journée aujourd'hui c'est un parcours
qui est difficile on le sait je suis
content parce que j'ai travaillé mon
putting en début de semaine j'ai eu un
petit moment d'entraînement avec un
expert du petit qui s'appelle david orr
et ça a vraiment bien marché on a changé
un petit peu mon putter aussi avec avec
alex d'un come on fit heures et ça a
bien fonctionné donc je suis je suis
vraiment content
tous
vendredi 18 octobre c'est reparti pour
une nouvelle journée de compétition les
températures avoisinent les 15 degrés la
principale difficulté aujourd'hui sera
le vent avec des rafales à près de 50 km
heure les spectateurs sont venus couvert
surtout un bonnet une écharpe et puis un
coup de vent voilà c'est ça
principalement et puis de temps en temps
se met à l'abri se protéger pourvu qu'on
ait pas d'eau c'est l'essentiel sur les
greens benjamin hubert le français
termine sa journée à la cinquième place
nicolas colsaerts et georges cotzee ont
pris la tête de la mundi open de france
avant le week end
super content parce que au début c'était
vraiment pas facile ça soufflait fort à
ses impôts recours compliquée à jouer
donc quand les conditions sont pas
faciles c'est avant tout aux plus dures
[Musique]
dernier jour de compétition de cet open
de france 2019 ce dimanche 20 octobre
nicolas colsaerts eux disposent de trois
coups d'avancé avant d'aborder le
dernier tour le golf le reste le favori
du public
tiens franco belge s'est peut-être
nichols art
on verra on verra il a du mal mais tout
le monde a du mal aujourd'hui les
pronostics qui se sont avérées justes
nicolas colsaerts remporté au trou
numéro 18 cette édition 2010 9 son
premier titre depuis sept ans le golfeur
termine 12 coups sous le par avec un
coup d'avancé
en conférence de presse le franco belge
de 36 ans lit ce moment avec sa famille
via son téléphone
c'est énormément de joueurs
voilà ça fait ça fait 18 ans que je suis
pro j'ai gagné deux fois jeudi gagner
plus souvent comme je l'aï déjà dit
souvent elle fait de gagner chez vous
c'est génial j'ai joué un peu
l'impression de faire partie du paysage
golfique français
de leur côté les français n'ont une fois
de plus pas réussi à dompter ce parcours
de l'albatros les chefs de file de la
délégation française victor perez et
benjamin hebert termine 16e
c'est un parcours que je connais bien
qui me résiste souvent a donc cette
année je suis content parce que j'ai
quand même réussi à faire une bonne
semaine pour les attend évidemment
toujours encore plus haut dans le
leaderboard
mais indéniablement c'est une bonne
année pour le golf français sur
l'european tour avec victor perez qui
la tête là du camp français actuellement
talonnée par benjamin hebert on n'oublie
pas également les jeunes pousses comme
romain gasc ou encore michael
lorenzo-vera cette 103e édition de
l'open de france de golf s'achève ici
sur le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
rendez vous l'année prochaine du 2 au 5
juillet à 2020 l'open de france qui
pourrait quitter est les yvelines en
2020 pour le sud de la france
l'information n'est pas encore
officielle mais la rumeur enfle depuis
plusieurs jours du 2 au 5 juillet les
meilleurs golfeurs français pourraient
se retrouver non pas sur le golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
mais à terre blanche un golf de haut
niveau situé dans la campagne varoise
près de cannes
objectif redonner un nouvel élan à ce
tournoi pendant une ou plusieurs
éditions
ce changement pourrait être officier
dans les prochains jours on écoute les
différentes réactions du monde golfique
présent sur le dernier open de france
le déménagement de l'open de france on
en parle actuellement mais alors il
faudra faire attention au niveau des
promoteurs parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'il ya un open qui sort de paris est
un open qui est en danger parce que le
nombre de spectateurs bas diminue de
énormément donc il faudra regarder les
chiffres et ferry faire vraiment
attention parce que il faut savoir que
l'opl organisation d'un tournoi comme ça
c'est vraiment pas donné on a la chance
de pouvoir jouer sur un des meilleurs
parcours montre encore une fois que tout
le monde connaît aussi à la télé se dire
que si demain on a un super je suis une
rude super dotation les gens qui vont
regarder ce tournoi à la télé que ce
soit les américains les européens vont
connaître par rapport à la ryder cup
on va maintenant parler de cyclisme sur
route la présentation du parcours
officiel du tour de france 2020 était
organisée ce mardi le peloton assez
lancera une nouvelle fois depuis les
îles ville pour rejoindre les champs
elysées pour décrypter cette nouvelle
grégory canal et nous avons rejoint sur
ce plateau bonsoir bonsoir michael alors
quelle ville a été retenue pour
organiser ce départ de tours le suspense
c'est la menace et mantes la jolie
après il ya en 2018 et puis à
rambouillet en 2019 les yvelines vont
accueillir pour la troisième année
consécutive la grande boucle cette année
c'est la ville du nord du département
qui a donc été retenues pour recevoir
l'événement ce sera le 19 juillet
prochain est la dernière fois que mantes
a vu passer ce tour de france était en
2014 lors de l'étape amiens chartres
écoutez à ce propos la réaction du
direct directeur technique national de
la fédération française de cyclisme
il ya une approche une approche intégrée
peau du privé jusque dans paris mais la
jolie ont souvent peine à donner 18 qui
a qui était belle réussite avec un joli
joli parcours qui avait fait la
sélection
voilà moi je suis très heureuse tout le
choix de mantes la jolie
est ce que c'est une surprise grégory
n'ont pas vraiment souvenez-vous le
département des yvelines et le groupe à
et son organisateur du tour de france
avait signé en mars 2019 une convention
pour accueillir les dernières étapes de
la grande boucle et ce jusqu'en 2023
seule la ville de départ changera chaque
année faut se souvenir que 2024 sera
l'année des jeux olympiques et que
département accueillera le vélo mais
au-delà de ça le vélo dans les yvelines
c'est un bel os partage c'est un vélo
pour visiter c'est aussi un vélo santé
c'est un vélo pour tous puisque le
département à 850 km de voies cyclables
cette année près de vingt mille coureurs
sont venus à rambouillet pour voir le
tour de france et la victoire du
colombien et gagnent bernal à
mantes-la-jolie espère faire bien voir
nous merci grégory pour toutes ces
précisions
focus maintenant sur les championnats
d'europe sur piste la compétition s'est
déroulée la semaine dernière à appel
d'air nos pays bas les pistards français
qui s'entraîne quotidiennement vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
ont réussi à ramener huit médailles dont
l'or dans leurs valises dont cinq en or
mention spéciale à la pistarde de 20 ans
mathilde de gouel remporte l'or sur le
keirin
mention spéciale également quentin
lafargue du vc au sky qui a remporté
l'or sur le kilomètre pour rappel cette
épreuve contre ap dans le processus de
qualification pour les jeux olympiques
de tokyo à l'année à prochaine on
continue à parler de cyclisme sur piste
masters cette fois il l'a fait y'a
nigeria a remporté son au premier titre
de champion du monde master si la
semaine dernière à manchester pour nous
parler de ce titre nous recevons yani
jarrier sur ce plateau on s'enrichit
pour st michael tout simplement votre
première réaction suite à ce cette
victoire
satisfait simplement parce que ben voilà
ça fait ça fait plusieurs années que je
participe au championnat master j'avais
souvent des s'achever j'ai fait deux
médailles d'argent déjà donc
donc voilà la maintenance etc le titre
et c'est l'aboutissement d'une grosse
année de préparation
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence cette
année qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
gt gt plus fort que les années
précédentes
meilleur chrono en 2017 étaient 10 713
et là j'ai fait j'ai fait 10 496
voilà c'est une amélioration de la
performance et puis donc ben du coup les
adversaires les adversaires n'étaient
pas n'était pas suffisamment
suffisamment fort pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir passer quoi voilà la catégorie
masters c'est quoi exactement
ce sont des coureurs qui ne connaît
absolument pas le site is ce sont des
pratiquants du cyclisme qui ont plus de
35 ans et qui ne qui ne font pas partie
des équipes nationales au delà 35 ans à
très haut niveau sur piste il y en a pas
le seul coureur qui a eu un titre
olympique c'est chris hoy et de mémoire
il avait 35 ou 36 ans
voilà donc donc moi je suis en catégorie
master 3g j'ai 43 ans donc
donc voilà on est on est sur nos années
vieillissante mais mais bon avec des
belles préparations avec des bons
entraînements et des objectifs bien
ciblés ben on arrive encore à améliorer
les performances puisque la voilà sur
les deux dernières années j'ai encore
gagner trois dixièmes sur le sur le 200
m lancé quoi sur les qualifications
justement votre entraînement il était
comment du rhdp ou pas du tout et je
suis ça fait ça fait quand même
longtemps je m'entraîne j'ai jamais eu
l'impression que c'est très dur
maintenant voilà cette année j'ai passé
j'ai passé presque six mois de l'année
avec des courbatures
presque tout le temps de janvier jusque
jusqu'au mois de jusqu'au mois de mai
jusque jusqu'aux championnats de france
voilà jusqu'à alléchant quatre ans avait
lieu mi juin
et donc oui jusqu'à rennes jusqu'à fin
mai c'était ça a été cinq mois de
courbatures
toutes les semaines donc oui bien sûr
que c'est dur mais les se fait reprendre
la phrase d'un grand champion de roller
que je que je connais bien et qui dit
les quelques secondes passées sur un sur
un podium font oublier toutes les toutes
les heures de souffrance à
l'entraînement donc
nous voilà ouais bien sûr que bien sûr
que ces difficultés bien sûr que c'est
mais ça reste du plaisir personne de
force à l entraînement personnes
m'oblige à me faire mal et et puis bah
voilà à briser les fibres musculaires
pour pour pouvoir obtenir le meilleur
d'elle mais voilà oui je le fais je le
fais toujours par park les siens à
remporter deux médailles et ce beau
maillot vous avez justement expliquez
nous ce maillot vous allez le porter
pendant 2 ans à 1 an pendant un an
car c'est à lui de chaque fois d'europe
que je garde depuis depuis maintenant
trois ans parce que voilà tant que la
compétition n'est pas reconduite et bien
je suis toujours champion d'europe mais
ma meuf champion de france champion du
monde voilà je suis je suis champion du
monde jusqu'à l'année prochaine et donc
bah je vais pouvoir courir sur les
épreuves de vitesse et les épreuves de
vitesse par équipes avec ceux avec ce
très beau maillot et puis je le porterai
aussi tendance à l'entraînement de leurs
questions a remporté deux titres
individuels et par équipes
quel est votre plus beau titre le
premier le premier l'individuel bien sûr
que c'est vrai que j'étais seul sur le
podium
ces deux saveurs complètement différente
parce que parce que je peux pas je peux
pas nier que ce ce titre avec sébastien
et arnaud c'est pareil ça fait quand
même quelques années qu'on fait les
coéquipiers voilà c'est vrai que ça fait
ça fait quand même quelques quelques
années qu'on fait la vitesse ensemble et
puis ben on a été deux fois deuxième
une fois manchester une fois los angeles
et là c'est pareil on arrive à gagner et
on gagne avec seulement quatre centièmes
donc c'est vrai que c'était un beau
titre parce qu'ils étaient avec une
grosse adversité
les anglais étaient était vraiment très
très fort merci bien du jarrion
continuera évidemment à vous suivre le
jeu rappelle que vous êtes également
chroniqueur de l'émission si on parlait
sport on retrouvera mercredi prochain
aux éditions alaska on voit en très
grande forme
on continue à part du football les
invincibles de versailles sont tombés à
ce week-end sur le terrain de saint leu
après 20 matches sans défaite sur deux
saisons les joueurs de la cité royale
ont perdu sur la plus petite des marges
à 1 0 au classement les versets ils sont
toujours premier avec 18 points en sept
matches ils pourront se rattraper le
week-end du 2 novembre à domicile contre
noisy le grand du football encore avec
le championnat de r2 ont joué ce
week-end la 5e journée trappe s'est
incliné pour la quatrième fois en cinq
matchs cette saison l'équipe coachée par
ludovic gauthier a perdu sur son terrain
face à val d'europe 1 but à 0 au
classement les trappistes son 11e sur 12
équipes engagées cette saison l'objectif
du club le maintien est pour l'instant
au compromis du rugby à présent avec le
championnat de fédérale 2 les plaisirs
ont logiquement logiquement perdu ce
week-end contre l'une des plus grosses
équipes de la poule bové ils ont
lourdement chuté sur le score de 53 à 12
sur leur terrain un match à sens unique
qui n'arrange pas les yvelinois qui se
retrouve à la 9e place du classement
avec huit points en congé depuis le
début de la saison on ouvre une page
handball à présent plaisir enregistré ce
week-end sa deuxième victoire de la
saison contre boigny dans un match
accroché jusqu'à la dernière minute
cette victoire à domicile leur permet de
remonter au classement de nationale 3 le
résumé du match des images de marylène
iapichino un montage de jus l'ogre
neuville un choc dans la lutte pour le
maintien plaisir aux sauver l'équipe de
boigne et à l'occasion de la 4e journée
de nationale 3 deux équipes qui
comptabilisé seulement une victoire
depuis le début de la saison
après une première période équilibrée
les deux formations regagnent les
vestiaires au coude à coude 14 à 13 pour
les visiteurs à la mi-temps première
mi-temps défensivement on n'était pas
vraiment en place
on n'a pas récupéré sept ballons pour
pouvoir monter les ballons
rapidement et on attaque là c'était un
peu stérile au niveau du mouvement
on n'arrivait pas à trouver les bonnes
courses extérieur on joue beaucoup
beaucoup centrale en deuxième période
les plaisirs war reviennent avec de
meilleures intentions et creuse l'écart
le tableau d'affichage indique un + 5 en
faveur du club local après 11 minutes de
jeu mais plaisir se fait peur et
l'emportent finalement d'un petit but
25-24 falloir réitérer ce genre de
performance parce que je pense que ça va
pas nous sourire à chaque fois si on
joue comme ça
mais bon je pense que là on a passé une
semaine d'entraînement qui était un peu
n'était pas au niveau d'une équipe de
nationale 3 ça se voit sur le terrain
je leur ai dit on avait une jambe un
petit message au passage il va falloir
qu'on se remette vite au boulot parce
que les
onze équipes arrivées on a besoin de
temps après cette deuxième victoire en
deux matches plaisir grimpe au
classement les plaisirs oies sont dans
le ventre mou à la 7e place
l'objectif pour là saison c'est
d'engranger le plus de matchs l'année
dernière
on est sauvé sur un changement de
règlement donc là c'est de gagner le
plus de matchs pour se redonner
confiance et plus d'être le plus haut
possible
après voilà on à équilibrer le bilan 2
victoires 2 défaites on faire en sorte
que le bilan est positif
prochain match pour le plaisir handball
club le samedi 2 novembre sur le terrain
de mussipontain une autre équipe qui
devrait jouer le maintien cette saison
on continue à parler de handball coup de
projecteur sur les féminines de monti le
bretonneux l'équipe est actuellement
première de son championnat de nationale
2 avec quatre victoires en quatre
matches disputés pour nous parler de cet
excellent début de saison nous recevons
sur ce plateau le président christophe
reding ainsi que les joueuses à nina
jerry tchatche et anna reading bonsoir
alors est-ce que vous vous attendiez un
début de saison canon comme celui là
christophe reading avec plaisir qu'on
l'accueille ducasse sera produire des
choses on se prépare en tout cas on
s'est préparés déjà depuis le mois de
mai l année dernière sur notre
recrutement est sûre en fait la
préparation puisque la cohésion avec
l'intégration de nouvelles joueuses qui
avaient déjà un niveau national une
maintenant voilà le résultat est au
rapport du travail qui était qui étaient
apportées en avant nina vous validez
travail à l'intersaison
c'est ça on a préparé ses on a commencé
la préparation mi août et elle était
bien présent on a fait des efforts pour
se préparer vraiment bien physiquement
et je pense que ça joue au hockey on a
bien commencé ce début de saison et pour
mon opinion c'est très positive et
j'espère que ça va continuer comme ça
alors ce week-end où vous avez valider
votre quatrième victoire face à dreux
sur le score de 26 à 22
est ce que vous nous en dire un peu plus
anna est ce que ça allait dans la
continuité des autres matchs que vous
avez à disputer cette saison apparaît
non c'est pas ça va être un match
moi je ne sens pas si simple mais on a
été un peu surprise va par un certain
relâchement puisqu'elles sont
actuellement
elle avait perdu 3,3 un match qu'on
avait gagné 3 je pense qu'on n'a pas
pris le match de la bonne façon mais
malgré cela en fait on a réussi quand
même à tenir jusqu'au bout
et puis arraché en fait ces trois
banques qui sont vraiment important
surtout pour respecter nos objectifs
nina ce match là où vous l'auriez
peut-être perdu la saison dernière ça
s'est compliqué à dire vraiment ça je
peux pas et se ferait donc qu'est-ce qui
fonctionne plus qu'une dernière dans
l'équipe ça ne sentait l'équipe peut
avec plus de cohésion peut-être ya plus
de collisions sont utiles de cohésion il
ya aussi des joueuses aujourd'hui qui
ont une vraie plus value au sein au sein
du groupe
on a également un entraîneur aujourd'hui
qui est qui a été recruté
comment dire avec sur une équipe qui
était sur un niveau national une prime
ça devient tout à fait qui a une
approche peut-être un peu différente qui
est en fait très pratique très
techniques est en fait tant l'idée c'est
d'amener du lien avec les avec les
joueuses et celui en là en fait c'est la
positive attitude
et derrière ça mais les résultats sont
là il ya un changement de coach
qu'est ce que ça a changé avoue qu'il
est au club depuis yop mal d'années
brahim apporte une toute nouvelle
dynamique on n'avait pas forcément mais
avec nos précédents entraîneurs
puis il a également aussi apporter de
nouvelles joueuses qui ont apporté leur
propre talent et expérience de national
donc ce qui c'est aussi un bon atout
c'est ce qui manquait aussi je pense
sinon opinons les années précédentes
c'est à dire de la fraîcheur et puis il
permet aussi qu'on garde pour devenir
une certaine rigueur pendant nos
entraînements il tout en étant en fait
sérieux se concentrait met du temps une
bonne atmosphère en fait je pense que
c'est très important
nina vous êtes premier renvoi classement
justement vous n'avez pas peur d'être
trop attendu maintenant
miroku cet effet de surprise voté non en
fait moi j'ai pas peur d'adversaires moi
les seuls peur que j'essaie des
blessures qui peuvent nous empêcher de
cette bonne dynamique qui en a c'est la
seule peur que j'ai sinon je suis
persuadé que l'on peut gagner tout le
monde dans cette division président est
ce que vous pouvez monter cette année en
nationale 2 alors michael par rapport à
cette question je vais être très prudent
oui on peut monter mais aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas forcément l'objectif premier
l'objectif premier c'est de bien se
préparer c'est aussi de respecter nos
adversaires et le shaq objectif est
donné chaque semaine c'est à dire c'est
le match suivant et on regarde ça à la
fin d'année en comptera des points
pourquoi je dis ça je reste très prudent
pour plusieurs choses mais la première
c'est qu'on est déjà dans une poule qui
est très homogène
ici paris et est premier sur les trois
productions mais les trois premiers
matches est en fait aujourd'hui au
placement ils sont
ils sont cons me dire bien redescendu
c'est à dire qu'on fait là au moins huit
équipes sur 12 aujourd'hui peut gagner
ce championnat
donc par rapport à ça il faut surtout
rien comment dirais-je vendre avant
avant la fin du championnat tout peut se
jouer à chaque week-end merci à tous les
toilettes passé sur ce canton continuera
évidemment à vous suivre tout au long de
la saison sur tb 78 la 10e édition du
trail des sept hameaux s'est déroulée ce
dimanche 20 octobre un départ donné
depuis magny les hameaux à 8h30 précises
des conditions climatiques compliquées
pour les 500 participants avec un
parcours de 35 km un reportage de
nicolas d'henri l'imperméable
l'équipement de rigueur pour cette
dixième édition du trail des sept
hameaux ce dimanche 20 octobre sous la
pluie et l'humidité de la forêt les
quelques 500 trailer ont pris le départ
du 35 km autour de magny les hameaux
fait bout tant les conditions étaient
optimales on n'aura pas trop chaud mais
ça va être sympa comment vous allez
gérer justement ben on va partir un peu
tranquille et puis garder un petit peu
du pur à partir du 20e km pour finir
tranquille j'ai mille pantalons
imperméables à vestes imperméables et
puis on va apprendre à prendre son temps
et faire attention aux mets les pieds
parce que ça risque de glisser c'est ce
qu'on aime qu'on fait du 13 je pense
c'est se lever tôt et puis coulé dans la
boue quoi donc même en bonne condition
pour un trailer
le parcours je pense qu'il faut c'est
800 dénivelé donc c'est pas non plus
énorme
donc faut partir assez fort je pense
continuer assez fort et puis finir finir
un peu fort le village de magny les
hameaux le site de port royal des champs
les traileurs suivent un parcours à la
lisière du parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse
il est assez technique on essaie on
essaie d'utiliser au maximum les petits
sentiers d'éviter les traversées de
route au maximum donc le bitume
donc c'est voilà il ya pas mal de
singles bien cassant des bonnes
descentes des bonnes montées faut
relancer les débats allaient pas facile
hein le rendez vous est pris en 2020
pour une onzième édition du trail des
cet amour on va terminer par de la voile
et plus précisément la transat jacques
vabre un robot little louis burton va
participer à cette course au large qui
va relier le havre au brésil le
navigateur sont rendus avec l'un de ses
amis de toujours davy beaudart le départ
sera donné ce dimanche depuis le havre
louis burton et son coéquiper devrait
arriver à la mi novembre au brésil
s'il n'y a pas de problème sur l'eau
c'est la fin de cette fuite sport merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]